Alex Jones a radio host known for his
Hyperbole and kind of eccentric bizarre
really out there kind of implausible
take sometimes that guy because he got a
story wrong on the air has to pay a
billion dollars
that's a lot of money for getting
something wrong on the radio don't you
think
but Michael he got it really wrong yeah
okay but Michael it was awful what he
said sure Michael it was really really
awful yeah okay fine I'm not I'm not
arguing I'm not I'm not disputing that
what kind of damages
are we going to see paid out by the
people who who lied about the covid
vaccines and who got the covid vaccines
wrong and who said that not only would
they protect you from getting the virus
and and transmitting the virus but uh
that they would actually they were
totally safe totally effective and now a
bunch of kids are dead because of heart
problems that even the CDC now admits
the vaccines cause very serious heart
problems and the ones that don't cause
heart problems cause blood clots